I had been a journalist for about eight
and a half years.
I was kind of an accidental journalist.
I never really intended to be a
journalist side.
Uh,
was fortunate enough to fall into a job
at the New York times when I got out of
college.
And it was a great experience when
you're in your twenties to see the world
and meet interesting people and be
involved with interesting issues.
But as time went on,
I said to myself,
you know,
I never really thought about what I
wanted to do with my life.
Um,
I'd like to see what it's like in effect
on the other side of the curtain to see
what it's like to actually be the one
doing the deals,
not just writing about the deals.
And so I decided as kind of an
experiment to go try it,
thinking I would do it for a couple of
years and if it didn't work out,
if I wasn't any good at it,
if I,
if I didn't like it,
I could come back to journalism and I
ended up staying 25 years.
I think journalism today is in a very
interesting place.
Uh,
I wrote in my book about some of my
grievances being on,
on the other side of the line from the
journalist in terms of how I think
journalism has changed in the 30 years,
roughly since I was in Washington as a
journalist,
um,
where I think it has become much more
game of spinning and being spun much
more game of.
Gotcha.
Um,
and I think all of that is part of why
the tonality in our society is pretty
rough at the moment.
I think.
I don't blame journalists for all of it.
Uh,
I don't blame the government for all of
it,
but I think there is a shared
responsibility that right now isn't
being discharged.
Uh,
and I think there's been a bit of a
dumbing down of journalism.
I think the whole sound byte journalism,
uh,
the blogosphere,
the cable,
the hyperventilated,
cable TV journalism,
I'm not sure how great any of that is,
but I was just a few minutes ago having
a conversation with someone about the
other side of the coin,
which is you had this enormous pro
proliferation of journalistic outlets,
like big thing that didn't exist,
couldn't exist a few years ago.
And so in the course of trying to sell
my book,
I've been interviewed by all kinds of
media outlets that didn't exist and as I
said,
couldn't have existed a few years ago
and in,
in a way that's a kind of golden age of
journalism that there are so many more
ways now to communicate and learn
things.
So I certainly wouldn't hesitate to tell
a friend or a child to go into
journalism,
but I think you really have to pick your
spots and know what you're in for.
My whole career in finance was going
from bigger firms to smaller firms and
at each step,
step of the way,
all I wanted was to be part of a small
group of very talented people on every
firm.
I joined got bigger and so finally I
decided,
uh,
starting our own firm would be the next
great thing to do.
It was a point in time,
this was in the year 2000 when it was
relatively easy to start a firm.
There was a lot of capital,
there were a lot of investors around and
there's no,
there's no sense of accomplishment like
starting a firm or a business as I'm
sure you're finding a from scratch and
watching it succeed and grow and thrive.
If you want to be an entrepreneur,
which is a wonderful thing to aspire to,
you have to,
there are several things you have to
have.
First,
you have to be completely committed and
devoted to that enterprise or project or
whenever you take on.
It's not something to do in your spare
time.
It's not something to do while you have
a couple of other careers.
It's not something to do.
While you write your first novel,
it's something you've just got to do.
The second thing is you've got to have a
very strong constitution.
There will be bumps in the road,
there'll be ups and downs,
you,
they may well be complete failure.
Many entrepreneurial ventures fail.
Um,
you have to accept that that is part of
the game.
And failure is not the end of life.
It's not the end of the world.
Uh,
and you just have to be willing to roll
with the punches and take risks.
You have to basically be a risk taker.
Many people spend their entire careers
happily in established organizations
because they don't have the tolerance
for risk.
I frankly never thought I would have the
tolerance for risk.
I've always been part until we started
our firm of,
uh,
of an established large organization.
But having been part of now one startup,
I think there's nothing else quite like
it.
If it works,
and I could easily imagine doing
another.